reject nation we're gonna do it try not
to laugh here and i figured
it's best to have a woman by my side for
this one so i got tara erickson today
that's me hi hello
family guy roasting every woman
compilation let's do it
don't get too offended womany
woman named mansplain your feelings in
advance
this is nothing new to me gregory
yourself know the difference between
comedy and straight man and
facts
[Laughter]
let me fix my bangs yeah i need
headphones for this huh
yep why don't you mansplain to me how i
need headphones to listen to sound huh
let's do this
peter you're not still friends with that
idiot after what he did
well i mean that may be a little harsh
i'm not going to avoid peter like the
drunk chick at a party
[Music]
well it hasn't been easy between doing
the laundry and vacuuming i barely had
time to put on a nice sweater and clasp
a cup of tea with two hands
and now to tie this sweater around my
waist and walk around the neighborhood
hang on i'll be right back lois i'm just
going across the street peter you can't
keep using cleveland's bathroom
oh my god yes i can cleveland's bathroom
is the greatest discovery since fat
women discovered diet coke
now i can eat anything it's just
complicated that's all
now trying to get a straight answer out
of a 23 year old girl is complicated
so do you want to go out sometime out
like go out or hang out or just do
something
like a date like a date date or like a
date both
i guess yeah sure maybe i don't know yes
no here's the first three digits of my
phone number email me
oh boy this is fine except for the fact
we're gonna sit next to that woman who
came with her co-workers
aren't we all pals i work at the office
this is empowering
maybe i'll get a dance huh you guys are
probably gonna be talking about this
forever
a woman who's so cool with all of this
jackpot
well it's probably the right move anyway
those girls seem kind of annoying
look at him over there taking a group
picture together i love you
i love you we're all such good friends
you can tell by the way we're pressing
our faces together
oh and that's where fat girls come from
so
we were supposed to go to the library to
white boogers in fancy books
i like to wipe mine in bronte novels
it's like a time bomb to gross out
lonely chicks
oh heathcliff oh come on i want so
little
oh wow you are definitely not afraid of
dessert
you know i wish i were secure enough to
throw on any old thing and call it an
outfit
come on you have so much body confidence
i mean who wouldn't with those strong
legs so muscular hey i like your tie
thanks
[Music]
peter why don't you just sit in that
booth over there man that's where the
after work secretary sit
what about mr jennerson is he single i i
don't know what about mr adelaide is he
single
i don't know who that is well who do you
know who is single uh
i'm assuming you oh hey look cake
excuse me can i get directions to the
providence civic center
[Music]
do you like cake yes do you like my ass
yes do you want to eat cake off my ass
what kind of cake angel food cake
well rusty looks like we're on our way
out of another jam
exit's coming up half a mile
you'd think i could find it yeah yeah i
would
i would okay i'm taking 4.95 here it is
it says take 24 to 128.
women we have spent decades fighting for
our right to vote
so when you go to those booths and cast
your ballot remember
warren g harding is way the cutest
and then we have a chocolate chocolate
cake that's infused with chocolate
served with chocolate ice cream and a
molten chocolate topping we'll have one
of those with four spoons
more like four of those with one spoon
for me
oh god help us
oh could i just try a little sample oh
sure it's so funny oh
i better just stick with the sand blower
i'm so bad
but at least i know i'm bad so that
makes me a little less bad
or worse that was the right thing to do
peter hey tyler are you on your way to
algebra
yeah i'll see you there
[Music]
you're awful the proceeding joke was
brought to you by
men that's pretty funny we don't know
what we did because 911 changed
everything brian
911 changed everything peter you didn't
even know what 9 11 was until 2004.
that's not true brian i remember 911.
must have been a woman piler there
come on guys we don't have to make such
a big thing about it it's not like i'm a
woman who's about to turn 30.
you guys i don't care what we do for my
birthday as long as it lasts the whole
week and it's very expensive and
inconvenient for all my friends
oh and i'm gonna dress like a [ __ ] and
be rude to everyone for no reason
but maya i don't care that your dad's
dying we're all going to montreal for
the week
not like 37 year old woman on a blind
date fund
so what if you forgot your wallet i'll
pay i'm gonna pay for us
you'll get it next time yeah so you were
in prison right
killed a man i'm sure it was in
self-defense
no i just felt like killing
oh you tell the best stories me and my
three eggs are having the best time
oh my god i hate it you're on the verge
of becoming that woman terry
i work out seven days a week for these
five minutes your attention is going to
keep me from swallowing a bottle of
pills you listen to me you son of a
[ __ ]
i've got one thing in this lifetime one
thing
you always say i never do anything
around here yeah i like saying that more
than i like you doing things
yeah i got the rest from the car you
were right she didn't appreciate it oh
crap
that's right i do groceries mom you get
crazy when you're pregnant
just like moms and radiohead oh no
no no this isn't music no i don't like
this david
no that's enough no david i don't like
that
no well it's a nice apartment you have
is this your dog
yes isn't he the cutest little cutie
booty
look how cute he is yes he's very cute
yes he's cute
yes he's cute cute cute look at him look
at him look at him
okay look at it look at that face
[Music]
go up what do you think just go up
sorry okay can everyone just stop
freaking out and just give me like
two minutes god
everyone's always yelling at me all the
questions
all right well maybe we'll turn you on
later and see how you feel
hello oh jesus it's a girl
may i speak to the man of the house this
is the woman of the house and there is
no man living here
no wait what is i how are you paying for
this phone
i'm a lawyer oh i see and are you in
your little courthouse right now
representing barbie
oh my god i know like when a woman in a
porsche cayenne isn't a complete [ __ ]
huh well i did not expect that
i wasn't telling you to go i was trying
to smell my own fart
peter you left the flap open like a
thousand degrees in here lois oh
now it's freezing headline woman cold
why do women have boobs so you got
something to look at while you're
talking to them
[Music]
so you've got something to look at while
you're talking about oh my gosh
you wanted to see me mr weed
irrational and emotionally fragile by
nature female coworkers are a peculiar
animal they are very insecure about
their appearance
be sure to tell them how good they look
every day even if they're homely and
unkempt you're doing a great job muriel
and you're prettier than maybe van doren
[Music]
god this place officially sucks worse
than the wnba
and at the top of the second half it's
16 to nine easton leads the scoring with
four
and that's why she commands seven
thousand dollars a year
these gals sure do make it look
difficult but is having this minor skill
worth being so unattractive
that's for the fan to decide yay barry
was over last night
don't tell me he left the toilet seat up
oh i ran into frank it's funny he fought
in vietnam he's an exorcist
but there is one thing that terrifies
him commitment
oh midge you're my third best friend in
the whole world
third who were the first two ben and
jerry
are your feelings hurt are you hurt are
you offended tara
no we have been dealing with
men since the day we were born this is
like nothing new
family guys just like really hits it
really hard though that i assume like
most women might be offended but i'm
like
yeah this is this is life
this is life and how this is accurate or
this is life and how this is what women
get made fun of for
a bowl she just labeled it
boom shaka i kept thinking with the
coworker bits of like are these the fox
employees that the family guy
staff works with didn't they just make
fun of them
todd wrote that about us yeah exactly oh
but this woman right here on the blind
date 37 year old
i was like me and my three eggs are
having a great time
you see every time tara comes over i
don't see her for many months and then
we end up having this like super serious
life discussion
for like 40 minutes it never fails
never plan it we wish it happened today
yeah and i was like damn we should have
filmed forever ago
i was like hey this is on topic
i'm on the verge of like this yeah it's
so funny to see that on here but i'm
glad you could take a joke
like i can take a joke gregory these
aren't that bad
these aren't i don't think they're that
offensive i mean i can't speak for women
so it's not right for me to be like this
the guy in the room
has the guy in the room don't get your
feelings hurt okay
i mean they're they're whatever they're
jokes like i
i always look at it like haha i get it
it's a joke i'm not a person who's
easily offended though
i've in the entire time i've known you
i've never seen you actually get
offended
no i just kind of like oh yeah that's
life
ortera has major depressive problems
yeah
it's the way we deserve to be treated
[Music]
was there one in here that you would say
is the most offensive or the most mean
oh god honestly my favorite one is the
one where the women are at the table and
they start eating each other's faces oh
my god the terrifying i hate it i think
the
the most like real is when he says
something about a woman who turns 30
and you like become invisible i'm like
that is so true oh
it's weird but it's true but it's all
about looks right it's all about looks
baby
gotta keep working on that ass and maybe
reel in a a few of those puppies and by
puppies i mean men
yeah when i relate to most is when peter
was like you always complain about me
not doing something around the house
when you do something they're like don't
do that
that's my job hey gregory thanks for
bringing up that i live alone and i
don't have anybody to help me with
anything
and now
is where you start crying represented
throughout all this video all right guys
well
family guy that one home are you guys
offended are you a guy who's offended
if so stop i'll talk to you directly
mail stop stop telling those girls that
you'll see them in
algebra get your [ __ ] together all right
follow tara on her channel where she
does a whole bunch of wacky stuff
check her out on instagram she's killing
it how many followers you got now
26 000. it's more than i got doing all
right
that's pretty good god damn i try
subscribe click bells
visiting ent see you guys soon
is that that ent there we have it at the
end yeah
your nose and throat special is that
funny right that's funny it's comedy
[Music]
you